hi i'm andrew from the youtube channel
follow andrew you can check down in the
description and there'll be links to my
channel where i do video tutorials about
web design web development
technology CSS HTML photoshop UI UX and
other related technologies I've been
developing websites for over 20 years
now and so go ahead and check out my
channel if you like what you see here
and and come see some other stuff now in
this particular video tutorial we're
going to be learning how to create an
entire custom bootstrap theme for an
admin style panel from scratch and it's
sort of divided into three separate
parts the first part we're going to be
setting up NPM and web pack so that we
can configure bootstraps source files
that are written in sass and kind of set
setting up some automatic workflows to
help us when we development the second
part second part of the tutorial we're
going to be looking at creating just
some basic bootstrap templates things
that are common in admin forms like
forms something we'll tables cards
widgets things like that you may find
inside of a typical admin style theme
and then the third part of the tutorial
we're going to be customizing the
bootstrap experience by adding some
custom CSS overriding some of the
bootstrap JavaScript or rather the
bootstrap sass files to have some sort
of custom look and feel and layout and
design to our bootstrap admin theme so
that's kind of the three parts again
check down to the description if you
want to skip ahead to any particular
section back and forth throughout this
video I hope you'll learn something
so come follow along now the first thing
we need to do here is set up a project
folder so I've just got a simple folder
here a set up in Visual Studio code is
what I'll be using for the editor and
it's just called HQ - admin is my master
folder and inside of this folder we're
going to be creating several files that
configuration files to start off so what
we're going to go ahead and do is we're
gonna open up our terminal window and
we're gonna make sure that we add a
couple of files here
so the first thing we're gonna do is do
get in it and that is going to create a
regular empty git repository so that we
can track changes here
to our files and whatnot the next thing
we're gonna do is say NPM in it and
that's going to pull in the node package
manager into our folder so we can pull
in various packages and import those
into our project so the package name I'm
just gonna leave here at HQ admin you
can see I'm just gonna follow the
prompts here version 1 description that
will just call admin theme entry point
we'll leave at we're actually going to
call our entry point J ass slash app dot
J s is where our entry point is going to
be we're not gonna leave any types of
commands we're not gonna have a git
repository set up quite yet keywords
will just say admin theme and the author
all just says Andrew Wilson and we'll
leave the license at default and we'll
hey yes for all of that and then that
creates a couple of files for us now you
can see it says I can update to a new
version from five six to five six one so
make sure you have the latest version
probably want to run an MPA and run this
command right here before you start this
tutorial to make sure you're on the
latest version of node so you can see
what that did for us is it created a
file in here called package JSON and
this package has all those values that
we're gonna be using throughout this
tutorial we're gonna be adding quite a
bit to this here in a minute but that
gets the initial things set up nicely
for us now the next thing we're gonna do
here is we're going to create just a
file here and this file is going to be a
dot git ignore file so dot GI t ignore
and we want to add into this file the
node underscore modules directory this
way it won't track all of the scripts
that we import into the node modules
directory we don't want those as part of
our repository so we'll just add that
one in there for now and that's probably
good enough in our git ignore file for
right now next let's go ahead and
we're gonna install webpack so we're
gonna be using webpack as the package
manager which is going to automatically
bundle up all of our JavaScript files
into a single javascript file it's gonna
compress it for us it's gonna
automatically take our CSS and sass and
convert it to CSS and write that and
compress just going to do several things
for us so we're gonna be using the web
pack package manager in this tutorial so
let's go ahead and install that next so
again down here in our terminal we'll
run a couple of commands here so we're
gonna say NP whoops make sure you're
actually down in the terminal we're
gonna say NPM and install web pack now
we could run all these commands which -
- save dev we could run all these
commands on one single line however
gonna do most of them I'm going to do
most of them individually so you can
kind of see what they're doing so this
is going to install web pack for us this
will take just a minute has it downloads
here
the next command we're gonna be running
after this a webpack command is the web
pack command-line tool so in order to do
that we say in p-m install web pack -
CLI - - save dev that saved dev command
makes it so that this writes to the
development dependencies in our package
JSON file so that they're not included
as part of the production of
dependencies because this stuff is
course only used during development so
we'll go ahead and add that one
give a second for that guy to install
next we're gonna say npm install web
pack - dev - server save dev and this is
going to be the development server that
automatically will spawn when we're
creating our files it has supports like
hot reloading and a few things like that
so every time we hit command s and save
a file it'll automatically recompress
recompile our sass spit out the files
and refresh the browser for us so that's
kind of a nice feature there that we're
going to be using in that package next
thing we're gonna do is install NPM
install let's see here this one's going
to be the font awesome so we're gonna
say @ it's under the repository called
fort awesome / font awesome
- free there's a free and a pro version
we're gonna be using the free and then
this save dev as well so font awesome is
the icon font that is open source and
free that we're going to be using yes
not on this open source but it's free
we're gonna be using that to generate
all the icons for the various settings
and switches and toggles inside of our
admin theme so the command we use to
sort of crunch and make webpack do its
thing is npx webpack - - config and then
it's just the default name there which
is webpack config j/s this is actually
optional that it assumes that's the
default name so you don't need to patch
the - - config value unless you've
changed your name for some reason but
you run that command and this will go
ahead and take all the configuration
settings you have inside of your web
pack run them all and then spit out the
output stuff so of course we don't have
anything in our web pack config that j/s
file but i just wanted to show you that
command that you can use
okay next let's go ahead and
run a couple more commands here so we're
gonna continue installing things
next we need to install a theme called
fibers now the next couple of things
we're gonna be basing in our theme off
of bootstraps we're gonna also be
pulling in bootstrap
so let's come down in here we're going
to say npm install fibers - - save dev
and we'll pull that one in and then
we're going to be installing SAS SAS s
so we'll grab it next as soon as this
finishes up here
okay then npm install SAS and then same
thing here into our dev environment
and the next couple of things we're
going to install are going to be dealing
with live reloading our CSS pulling in
CSS the post CSS loader a few of the
things that basically are required for
bootstrap in order to import and
customize bootstrap we need these little
files because we're going to be working
with the raw sass files in bootstrap and
these things required so in a p.m. let's
see here install so we're gonna be
working with one called sass loader and
here I'm gonna do a couple at once we're
gonna be doing the node sass whoops and
we're going to be doing the CSS CSS
loader we're gonna need the autoprefixer
the post CSS loader if I can type this
right it's post CSS
- loader and we'll save all those to dev
as well if I typed all that out right
okay so this is gonna pull in all these
little different packages that it kind
of are required for working with
bootstrap and the next plug-in we're
gonna grab is one specifically used for
pulling out your CSS file and writing it
to an individual file so web pack by
default when it configures and packages
of your JavaScript files it also takes
all of your CSS and it jams it inside of
JavaScript and then hot loaves that or
pushes that into the browser via
JavaScript with inline style tags so if
you don't like all of your CSS jammed
inside of JavaScript this next little
plugin is a plugin that will take your
CSS export it out and write it as a
regular dot CSS file which is how I like
it
so in p.m. install mini - CSS - extract
- plugin save dev
okay we'll wait for a second for that
and let's see we have one or two more
here but that will probably do it for
now so the most of our files are now in
place and loaded up now let's go ahead
and check the node modules and you can
see just how many things came in from
all those commands we have all sorts of
stuff in here that is packaged as part
of all those imports so the one thing
here that we are missing is actual
bootstrap itself so we're gonna end
pull in bootstrap next
so we do that within p.m. install
bootstrap and this will pull in all of
the sass files CSS files and also all
the JavaScript files that are required
from bootstrap now you can see here when
we install bootstrap it tells us that
bootstrap requires a peer of jQuery and
popper
in other words jQuery and popper are
both dependencies that are required for
bootstrap to work this if you're going
to be working with JavaScript files so
we need to add those files so let's go
ahead and pull it in those guys so in
order to do that we can say in p.m.
install and then we're gonna save - -
save jQuery and popper is now we're not
doing save dev here because these need
to be these are actually production
files that are not part of our
development files so that's why we're
not saying save depth
same thing with the bootstrap dependency
we just pretty installed we want that
it's a required package not a dev
package okay so now we have bootstrap so
let's go ahead and peek over here at our
package JSON file and we can see kind of
what this is doing here
we have a bit of a problem so it looks
like our package.json file
is not getting up - and the issue here
maybe I just have an old one so it's
just
yeah there we go I was just looking at a
hood file I was little confused there so
you can see now our package.json file is
updated with quite a bit of things here
so you can see here's all of our
development dependencies with all these
things we just barely added and then
here's our required dependencies which
are the bootstrap and those two files we
just added there as well so that is
mostly set for our web pack or our sorry
our package.json file and now we can go
ahead and start the process of building
out this theme importing our files
setting up our web pack file so let's go
ahead and do that next so let's jump
over and create a few files we need so
we need to come over here and set up a
source file so we're gonna set up a new
folder it's gonna be source and this is
gonna be the folder that houses our raw
assets and inside of source again you
can really set this and configure this
however you want I'm just gonna set a
folder called JavaScript I'm also gonna
do a new folder called sass which is
gonna hold all of our CSS and sass files
are gonna be using to modify and build
this theme out so that's really all we
need there and then inside of our
JavaScript folder we're going to create
a new folder called app dot GS so that's
gonna serve as the main file that web
pack looks for to run its commands and
then we're gonna do a new file in here
also called customed
GS and that's where we'll write any
scripts or things like that we need to
write for our application that we want
to import into this main file so there's
a couple of those boilerplate files now
let's go ahead and set up our sass files
so we're gonna set up a new file here so
the first file we're just going to call
main dot s CSS so this is gonna be the
main sass file that houses all of our
imports where we're importing all sorts
of different CSS sass files all over the
place we're gonna create a fairly
modular layout so that it's easy to sort
of find you know if we're have a button
element it's gonna be in our button
Styles if we have a card element it'll
be in our card Styles so gonna be
sending out several
opponents so let's go ahead and set up
those folders for the components so
we're gonna set up a new folder here and
we're just gonna call this folder app as
it's gonna house all of the CSS files
for our app we're gonna set up another
file here that is called underscore VARs
dot s CSS so this file is gonna hold all
of our sass variables we'll set up
another one here and this one
specifically we're just gonna call it
customize - bootstrap dot s CSS and this
file in specifics is going to house the
variables that we're going to use to
override specific things inside of the
bootstrap sass files so this variable is
is going to be our own variables that we
do various thing with various things
with and the customized bootstrap will
be bootstrap specific variables so we'll
kind of separate those two out like so
alright so we have our main we have
those we have our app and we're gonna be
creating inside of our app three folders
so we're gonna be creating a folder
called components that's where we're
gonna house all of our various
components we're gonna have another one
called pages this will be a folder where
we'll house a page specific CSS so like
if we have a login page for our admin
theme that really doesn't belong with
all the other CSS so that's where what
kind of house things like that login
pages of contact pages maybe things like
that and then one more in here we'll do
a new folder we're just gonna call this
guy vendor and this is where we'll store
any CSS that's specifically created to
override vendor packages so one example
we're going to be using here in a minute
is we're gonna be using the pace
JavaScript library which enables you to
sort of have a loader to show the load
progress of your page as it renders and
it comes with its own sass files so we
can use this vendor folder to sort of
override and customize the look and feel
and colors of those loading bars that
our package based third-party packages
so that's where we'll put
that type of stuff okay so that's pretty
much the setup for our SAS folder so all
that stuff's going inside of the SAS
folder and we'll be creating all those
SAS files of course here in just a
minute
next let's go ahead and create our
front-end so that's just gonna be inside
of our demo and we're just gonna create
a new folder here and literally call it
demo I just don't think I just said that
wrong so this is gonna be like our
distribution a lot of times you'll see
this called dist
which is the files that are distributed
I'm just gonna call mine demo again you
can set this up really however you want
so inside of our demo we need a few
things so we're gonna create a couple of
folders here we need a CSS folder which
is gonna house our outputted CSS we need
a folder here for our fonts these are
going to be extracted an output from
font awesome and we need a new folder
here for our JavaScript which is going
to be whoops I think I could've that as
a subfolder I did get Ansel we want to
move it up into demo yes and our
JavaScript file will of course house all
of our JavaScript files that we have and
then we need one file here new file we
need an actual index.html file and this
file is going to be our our of course
applications HTML will live here so in
that's kind of a basic setup for our
distribution or our demo folder that's
really all we need inside of there if we
did have for example in our JavaScript
file we can create a new folder here and
we could call this like plugins or
something and then all of the external
javascript that comes from vendors we
could stick inside of there if we wanted
to link to that and inside of our
JavaScript folder we now need our output
file which is going to be our apt
jeaious output file but web pack is
going to create that for us and stick it
in there so we actually don't need to
create that file but that's eventually
where it's going to go
okay so all of those files are now in
place and let's go ahead and build out
our HTML file so that we can begin the
process of running web pack first to see
if it actually loads up so let's go
ahead and jump over here now to our
source folder we're gonna come in our
JavaScript folder here and into our app
KS and the first thing we're gonna do is
run the import command because we need
to bring in bootstrap that's one of our
required dependencies oops and we need
to import everything inside of our sass
folder so write everything inside of
here we basically want to bring in so
we're gonna say dot dot slash sass
because it's back a directory from this
JavaScript folder so hence the dot dot
slash then we need to bring in our
custom stuff so we're gonna import dot
slash custom so that's going to bring in
anything you know that we write inside
of our custom stuff and package all that
into a single single javascript file so
those are the three things we need
inside of our app dot jeaious so that
should be good there
okay the next thing we need to do is
configure our web pack JavaScript so
we're gonna come in here to web pack j/s
and add in all the configurations so we
can finally run web pack it's gonna do
its thing import bootstrap and then
create our files so let's go ahead and
add this next
okay now there's going to be quite a bit
of code inside of this configuration
file so we'll kind of go through it
piece by piece we can kind understand
this so the first thing I want to do is
add a constant of path equals require
path and this is just what's required
here for web pack and we actually I need
to add another constant for web pack
itself and will require web pack and
then we're gonna add another one and
this is going to be the mini CSS this is
the plug-in we added earlier extract
plug-in
whoops equals the chances I make a typo
in any of this are very high just so
you're aware so this is the plugin that
we downloaded it's going to extract our
CSS and then here we're going to do our
module dot exports so this is all the
configuration settings for all of the
various modules and things like that
okay so we're gonna start with the one
called dev server so this is basically
just key value pairs here in this little
it's a JSON type of object so dev server
is going to have the following
configuration so it's going to have a
content base and then we're going to say
path dot resolved and this is going to
automatically find the path where this
file exists this we're going to say
directory named demo so it's going to
look for its current directory and then
into the demo folder that's where the
dev server is going to be served from
we're gonna say compress true so it's
gonna compress our files whoops this one
I over here has to be a comma not a
semicolon because these are all the
values
and then we're gonna say public path is
set to demo as well so again this is
gonna be whatever you set your right
minds being served from this demo folder
right here if you called this dis tour
something you would of course update
these for that and then right to disks
is true now this one got me initially I
was having some issues with webpack
where it wasn't updating my sass files
when I would save it kind of looked like
it was but it actually wasn't working so
I had to actually add this flag right to
this true and that solved that issue for
me so that's pretty much it for the dev
server values so that's gonna make it so
that our dev server
you know uses those values when it
serves this then we're gonna add in here
the entry point for everything here is
dot source /j s slash app dot J s again
this is not standard standard I think is
just
camera was standard is indexed
javascript or something like that
the output
how put is going to be so the file name
is just gonna be app dot J's for me and
the path where I want that guy output is
going to be we can just say path dot
resolved again okay to fix that for me
directoryname and it's gonna be under
demo /gs so that's where mine is gonna
live
and that's probably non-standard as well
and the public path variable we can set
to demo whoops
demo I actually think the dev server
might use this public path variable when
it does this thing so I might not need
to declare it twice but
okay so that's good enough there next
let's go ahead and work on the module
so this is going to be some various
rules we're setting up that's going to
happen basically these are instructions
we want webpack to use when we run it so
we're going to be using this key called
rules and it's made up of a bunch of
configuration values so the first one is
going to be test and it's going to be
you
let's see if I type this correctly here
again this is gonna be a miracle if
everything goes off perfectly in the
first go by so SCSS
and I don't need that one Gama
okay and then we are going to
say use and use is going to be set up a
bunch of these as well so the first one
will be this this first one we're going
to be is the plugin that's going to be
used to extract the CSS into a separate
file so we're gonna say loader mini CSS
extract pull again loader so that's what
we need for that and then the next one
is going to be the loader for the CSS
loader
which is gonna load in our CSS the next
one and again I'll have these files is
somewhere you can download so copy paste
here is really gonna be your friend but
I wanted to kind of go through this
piece by piece by piece for I don't know
because I'm crazy for sanity sake
this next one is going to be used to
process our CSS with post CSS which i
think is actually required for to make
the bootstrap stuff work so we're gonna
say loader CSS loader whoops sorry
this is the post CSS loader post CSS
loader and we're going to be passing in
a few options here so the options key
and then the first thing is going to be
our plugins then we have a function here
function if I can spell that correctly
and I'm just going off my notes of
course because I don't have all this
memorize I have to look to stuff up
return and then we're gonna require
autoprefixer and autoprefixer I'm not
sure where that's hyphenated I think
it's better - its way my notes have it
anyway autoprefixer is the plugin that's
required for bootstrap sass files to
compile correctly so that's why we need
this
all right that's it
for the post CSS next we're gonna load
up our SAS loader so we need one more
here and this is going to be our loader
and this is gonna be our SAS loader to
process our SAS files and that's pretty
much most of the way done for webpack we
just need a couple of little more things
down here at the bottom we're gonna set
up some code that's going to make it so
that our web fonts get extracted and
saves to disk be the file loader and
then setup jQuery what the provide
plugin
that which is gonna make it so that our
jQuery dollar sign is a global variable
because webpack I don't think I don't
know how it packages your JavaScript but
it messes up with the global variables
so that is going to allow for that okay
and that we're going to add
it's getting so big I can't even see
that's going to be added right after
let's see the rules command I believe
I'm just double-checking here yeah so
after all of our rules so this is where
the this helps tremendously
the bracket matching highlighting an MDS
code so after our rules we're going to
set up a another section here and this
is going to be called test so this is
going to be the thing we're testing for
all the web fonts so this is going to be
our little
regex here slash dot
a couple of these okay so we're gonna
look b EO t files we're gonna be looking
for WOFF files we're gonna be looking
for w o FF 2 files we're going to be
looking at TTF files we're gonna be
looking to SVG files and that's it for
that and so all of those files are all
of the different ways that font awesome
packages its fonts because every single
browser requires a different font format
it's kind of ridiculous so they're sort
of stored in a million different ways
and then the browser will pick the
correct font depending on its needs
correct font files okay so that's why we
need to have so many of those and I do
not know what this regular expression
means somebody else probably does I
grabbed this from my camera where I
grabbed this from somewhere and then dog
John okay so that is supposedly the
regex that will do that for us I'm just
double-checking my no here really quick
to see if I see any obvious typos okay
now we're going to say use
and
this is going to be so we have here the
loader is going to be the file loader
and the options
you
are going to be named will be set to
[Music]
whoops name like this will be set to the
name
and then the dot
extension so this is how we want our
filename so it's gonna be the name of
the extension will come in just how they
found essentially and then the output
path it's gonna be dot dot slash fonts
now this is kind of important because it
depends on how you where you store your
font files but for where I stored mine
in my demo or distribution directory
this is the correct path if you will and
the public path is the same in my case
so essentially one of these store and
one of these references where the files
are and the other one is what actually
gets listed in your CSS file when it
references the font family and says
where's the font family it's gonna be
say dot slash so it's a relative file
path based on your CSS files location so
that's a very important to note ok so
that's pretty much it for the tests now
we just need to add our last two things
which is our
after our modules so clear up here so
after this guy now we're going to load
in the plugins that we so plugins and
let's say new we're going to load the
mini CSS extractor pull again first and
it's going to be passed in the following
options file name and this is just dot
dot slash CSS slash app dot CSS so
that's the file name that it's going to
create and save that to that location as
well when it extracts the CSS
and whoops one more plug in here we're
gonna say new webpack dot
provide pull again
and this guy is going to be past the
options this is where we're going to
make our global variable so we're gonna
say the dollar sign is for jQuery
and also jQuery like this
nextly I don't need to be in quotes just
just just a key jQuery like this is
going to be for jQuery as well
okay so that I think pretty much does it
for
that plugin I'm just double-checking
here
because I feel like I may have added
that wrong spot
yes I did so this plugins goes after the
module not the mod which will exports
had it in the wrong spot so it goes
right after this guy
like so
so then
I think we are good and again chances
this all compiles correctly is gonna be
a miracle but of course I'll have this
file listen you can download if things
don't go you know probably the easiest
as it was to skip to this point in the
video but I wanted to kind of go over
that all right so we're gonna save and
the one thing I did notice is that I
forgot we need the file loader plug-in
and I don't know if I installed that
with my last NPM commands so we're gonna
go ahead and do that right there NPM
install file loader oops
save dev if it's already there it'll
just add it again so it really doesn't
matter but I don't know if I did that
before so heads up there okay now we
have that web packed file all set we can
actually run the command I showed you
earlier to see if all of that stuff will
compile now in order for this to work we
need to set up an index file inside of
our demo so we do have our index that
HTML but let's go ahead and set up a
little bit of boilerplate code here in
this file first so we'll come in to this
index.html file and we're just gonna if
we just nvs code if you just do talk and
hit type it fills out all that
boilerplate for you with the emmett
script super super nice so this is
really all we need here for this the
only thing we want to do is we're gonna
create also a link so we'll say leak rel
equals stylesheet because we want to
link to the stylesheet that web pack is
gonna be creating for us H ref is going
to be set to CSS slash app dot CSS I'm
actually going to put a slash in front
us because we're gonna be using
development server so I want that to be
root relative
and close that guy off and then also
where you want to add inside of hair
down in our footer not our footer really
before our closing body tag I guess a
link to the JavaScript file so script
and we're gonna set the source on this
one is going to be in - slash Jayesh
slash app is that's the public path for
our demo or a distribution folder and
that should be good so we don't I don't
think need anything else in here let's
just throw ourselves a header one tag
for a hello world finally and let's see
if we can get this guy to run so what we
need to do here is now it execute that
command
so let's come I'm gonna try to back up
here in my history that's the one right
there
so MPX Westpac - config so this is gonna
make web pack look at our web pack dot
JSON or Jason how we want to say that
but I like JSON personally and then
execute all this stuff so when we hit
return here not return there down here
this is gonna have web pack try to do
this so we have an error it says can't
resolve source JSF dot J s and I think I
see the issue here so if we go to our
web pack file you can see that I said
dot source is supposed to be dot slash
source so I had a slash there to go into
that directory so let's go ahead and fix
that and run it again so we'll hit
return here see if we get some more
errors so we've got another one can't
resolve dot dot slash sass in our
JavaScript file so in this guy so dot
dot slash sass so
you
maybe it's because we don't have any
files anything inside here let's go ed
and try that let's add something to our
actual SAS file and see if that helps
so let's just say body background color
red so we'll save that and let's come
down here I don't think this is gonna
solve this issue
all right let's troubleshoot here okay
the issue here is that we can't just go
to a folder I need to specify a file so
I'm going to come to slash slash main
dot a CSS so this should come in and
grab that main file so let's come down
here and run web pack again
okay we have some more errors let's
track these down first one says cannot
find module autoprefixer so we possibly
spelled that wrong so earlier in the it
came up with the autoprefixer hyphenated
so let's try that and run this again
all right you found the issue here so
the thing is this does autoprefixer does
need to be included without a - like my
notes
the problem is earlier when we installed
the NPM apparently there's two packages
ones Auto - prefix er and the other ones
just autoprefixer I installed the one
with the - which is incorrect we need
the one without the - so you need to
install autoprefixer without a - back at
save dev then once you have that guy
installed let's just go ahead and run
web pack here again one more time you
can see now it runs through everything
without a problem and it compiles out so
let's go ahead and see what web pack did
for us so we're gonna come over here to
our output so let's come into demo you
can see that we have an app dot J's file
that web pack has created for us with
tons and tons of stuff so we have in
here this is basically all the
JavaScript that is from bootstrap you
can see here sizzle there's all sorts of
things in here but bootstraps Java
scripts in here we have our CSS so it
compiled and minified our CSS body
background color red and everything is
good to go so inside of our source woops
our demo we have all of that stuff in
place now the one thing we need to add
inside of our output folder is a place
for our web fonts
so we're eventually going to be adding
in here
to our demo we'll just create a new
folder right here and we're just gonna
call this guy BOTS because this will be
housing all of the fonts so perfect that
actually worked so now what we can do is
we can use NPM so instead of having to
type this command every single time we
can make it so that we can just say NPM
run build and everything will sort of
flow for us so what we have to do is
we're going to come back to our packages
dot JSON file now and we're gonna come
up here to our scripts section and we're
gonna add a couple of things right here
so we're going to add in the one called
build and it's going to execute the
command web pack and then if we have one
called start dev
we'll say this guy is going to execute
the command webpack - dev - server for
us okay so in other words we can come
down here to our terminal and let's go
ahead and clear this out
whoops not there so we can say webpack
because we installed this module earlier
dev - server and hit return though we
don't have did we install the web
fective sir I'm pretty sure we did
obviously installed so many things I
can't remember let's go ahead and just
double check that really quick and okay
we definitely did so what the problem
was I was using the wrong command so the
command we eat is actually this it's
node modules slash bin slash web pack
dev server so we have to go to the right
directory for we execute this command so
when we do this command this will launch
this dev server here
so what the dev server does is it
launches a server you can set up some of
these things but notice how it's being
served from my slash demo that's my
distribution folder automatically for me
and then it sets up a little dev server
so I can just copy this and we'll pull
up Firefox here and just paste that in
there and you can see that sure enough
it's pulling up everything from my dev
server so there's my index there's my
CSS fonts JavaScript and it's all
sitting right there as I would expect so
that is pretty slick now typing that
command over and over and over again
right every single time
you
now typing that command over and over
and over against a little bit cumbersome
so what we can do is I'm just going to
get out of that dev server that's why we
added this command right here so we can
say npm run or build and then we say
start dev and now when we do that we get
an error
you
because I typed it wrong it's npm run
not build start dev it's build on the
other one okay so we can just run that
command that will automatically execute
the web pack dev server command up here
start our dev server everything launches
up creates all our files and
everything's good to go so now we can
just again jump over here to the dev
server and it should be up and running
perfect so the one issue here is you can
see in our route this should be bringing
up my index.html file which it's not so
we need to jump back here to vs code and
just double check that we place that in
the right the spot
and we did not in fact I have no idea of
where we put that I don't see it
anywhere
I'm pretty sure all that we did we
created it in the wrong in the wrong
area so inside of our source
oh whoops I did it I did a bunch of that
stuff wrong earlier so we were just not
paying attention to where I was creating
those folders but our index our
JavaScript our fonts all these guys
should have been up inside of the CSS
demo folder way up here so let's just
how can we fix this easily we can
probably there's nothing in the any of
this stuff is there no let's just delete
this one out to get it
so we'll fix this by just deleting this
demo we're gonna grab this demo and move
it up
but not into node modules maybe I can
move it up I thought this would be easy
right there move
okay so now our demo is back at the root
it has its CSS fonts JavaScript okay
let's try this again so I'm going to get
out of the web server here it's coming
down the bottom and let's just run that
same command one more time so this
should package everything up launch our
dev server let's just double check that
it created the files sure enough it
created our CSS file it created our app
there is that file of our Jas so that
looks like it's working quickly there's
our index file is sitting inside of
there so now if we go over here and
refresh there we go we're now finally
seen the root of our app with our hello
world and our red background color so
that was about an hour of just setting
up and configuring everything to
actually then begin the process of
developing our custom theme so now we're
going to be adding in a whole bunch of
CSS and some boilerplate to build a
fairly robust admin theme and the admin
theme I'm using is I've taken a lot of
the ideas off of another admin theme and
used some of the CSS but I've also
heavily customized it to kind of fit my
needs so I'll link to that down in the
description for the base thing that I'm
basing this off of but let's go ahead
and get started with that next okay now
that everything is working for us here
in our dev server let's go ahead and now
import into our sass file of the
bootstrap files we'll set up a very
basic page and then we'll be off to the
races to create this full theme so back
over here we're going to open up our
main sass file in our source and do some
imports so we can go ahead and delete
this rule we added earlier we'll just
add in our little dock block here with
but that would actually psi
thing for that but it doesn't maybe it
does so we'll just say this is going to
be our HQ admin theme and we can give
ourselves an author
andrew wilson and we can give this
selves a URL es colon slash slash
youtube.com slash channel slash follow
Andrew anyway you get the idea right so
we can add in here at the top whoops
some of that stuff okay so the first
thing we're you need to import is
bootstrap itself so we're going to just
gonna do a couple comments like this so
we're gonna say at import this is the
sass now we're going to import our
variable dot s CSS file we're going to
import the customize bootstrap dot s CSS
file and then we're going to add import
the bootstrap itself so bootstrap s CS
SS CS s bootch drop like that so
basically this is gonna look inside of
the node module so if we come over here
we can find the bootstrap files right
here and you'll see inside of there an S
CSS file this is what its gonna be you
know it's gonna import all of this jazz
so they have a bootstrap file in here
right this is when we're importing and
their file imports a million and a half
other bootstrap files so we're importing
right tons and tons and tons of sass
files that is what that line does so
that is getting us all the bootstrap
files the next thing we need to do is
import font awesome so this is kind of a
little bit strange here but it's very
powerful so we're going to say FA we're
creating a variable called FA font path
and we're just gonna set that to the
path for font possums web fonts folder
so we're gonna say at fort awesome /
font awesome - free / s CSS /font
awesome dot s CSS okay so that is the
that's not their height that it is font
awesome
- free slash web fonts I got too excited
web fonts okay so that's the path there
and now we're going to add import
essentially now we can copy this and
kind of use part of it here
so the SCSS slash font awesome
- CSS now font awesome five version five
which is what we're using is quite a bit
different than version four it splits
off all of the different fonts into four
or five different CSS files we need to
import each one of those in addition to
the main font awesome file so I'm just
gonna copy this and we're gonna go one
two three more times so they have one
called regular they have one called
brands which is things like facebook
icons google icons brand icons and then
they have things called solid which are
solid icons and if you have notice how
every time I'm hitting command S it's
doing its thing right it's running this
and it just recompiled everything from
scratch so that's pretty cool
now we are going to so just to prove
this if we go over here and look at our
demo file and now look at our app dot
CSS notice how it's much much larger now
right this is all the bootstrap stuff
we're seeing inside of here there's all
the font awesome stuff we're seen inside
here so it's just importing and
compiling everything down which is very
very handy so that's it for font awesome
and the next thing we want to do is just
also to illustrate this if we look in
our demo folder now if I open up my
fonts now that I'm importing font
awesome notice there is all of the
various actual font files themselves
that will be served with the font
awesome so that's what that the file
extractor we did inside of our web pack
right down here so we tested for all
these different files and then extracted
them with the file loader and then stuck
them all right there so that's what that
little configure
setting did for us which is really
really cool font awesome five is
actually a bit I think more trickier to
customize and to use on your own like
this but it's doable with some of these
tricks
alright the next section here we're just
gonna call this section our app layout
so here we're going to add import and
this is the files that we'll be creating
so we're gonna say app slash components
slash app so again this file doesn't
exist yet but we'll be creating a master
CSS file for our app and notice we got
an error right there when it tried to
compile because this does not exist so
we will go create it so let's open up
app and we will create this file inside
of our components new file app dot s CSS
underscore that
and let's try to let's just do a rule in
here well if I'm going to be overridden
by all that other CSS let's try a body
just to see if this is working
background - color green and we'll add
an important on this to try to override
everything and save so
that looks correct
and let's see if this is actually
working now
so it failed to compile so let's go
ahead and let's run this dev server
again and see if it compiles okay so it
looks like an compiled okay that time
and let's go back to our and refresh and
you can see sure enough it's working
just fine
so now what I'm going to do is I'm going
to go side by side because we have sort
of live reload iam enabled on this so
I'm gonna pull this instead of
fullscreen here I'm gonna pull Visual
Studio instead of fullscreen now we're
gonna go to a partial screen as well so
over here and then we'll make this take
over the other half of the screen so now
we essentially can see our hot reloading
in action so watch what happens if I
change this to blue and just hit command
s it's gonna recompile everything and
refresh the browser and poof we get blue
so that is super super powerful okay
so we don't need to have this in here
let's just delete that and save that
we'll go back to our main sass file here
and we're gonna add in a couple more of
these
so there's our app layout we will add
three more here so I'm gonna copy this
and I'll say paste paste paste so we're
gonna have one called app we're gonna
have one called app - header whoops I
just delete it up app header we're gonna
have one called app - sidebar we're
gonna have one called app - sidebar many
and then we're actually gonna have one
more we're gonna have one called app -
title like so
alright so now
let's go ahead and create all these
files so we need at Petter app side bar
all these in here so let's come back to
our components where these guys all live
and we'll create them so new file
pap-pap - header a CSS and a new file
app - whoops forgot what I was typing in
there
sidebar next
pop - sidebar SCSS new file tap - title
I think we had that as CSS I can't
remember all these it keeps opening them
up as I create them I'll see we got
header sidebar title now we need to
sidebar mini so underscore app - sidebar
- mini dot s CSS okay so now we're gonna
come over here and save and it should
try to recompile and hopefully we don't
get any errors and it looks like that
worked just fine
so let's come in - maybe our app header
file and just throw in a couple of
customizations so we can kind of see how
this is going to change so let's say
again we're gonna do this just to make
sure everything is working
let me save three go it's working fine
okay so let's go ahead and add now some
code to our index.html file so that we
can then begin to flesh out a little
admin theme here so we're gonna jump
over here to
our demo whoops I was in the right spot
and index.html and we're gonna add some
code to our body tag so we're gonna get
rid of this hello world and actually add
in quite a bit of code here so this is
where we're gonna be integrating we're
gonna be using bootstrap so we're gonna
be using a lot of the bootstrap grid
which is based off a flex box and some
of their components and widgets and
whatnot as we start to build our admin
theme they're gonna heavily customize
the Apple a out with some left with some
sidebars things like that
toggle menus etc etc so let's begin the
process of setting up just a few HTML
files that we can learn a bit about the
basics of bootstrap before we start to
customize some of these components so
what we're going to do is we're gonna
come over here to our demo folder that
we set up and let's just create a new
file here for now we're going to call
this file first forms dot HTML because
forms are gonna be the first aspect
we'll tackle here so inside of this
forms folder I'm just gonna do a little
bit of copy-paste here I'll you can
pause the video here in a second when I
get this all set up here for you but
basically all we want here is just our
body tag and just our basic HTML here so
you can kind of see we've just got our
head tag we'll call this one the forms
page we're linking out to our CSS sheet
that we have set up that web pack is
configuring for us and that's pretty
much it so we're gonna have a class on
our body of app and that's pretty much
all we we actually don't even need the
sidebar mini there and then we're gonna
write a little bit of bootstrap code so
let's start out here and we're gonna
write just a little bit of code that
will help us get a column or two so
we're gonna be adding two columns we're
going to be we're going to be using the
bootstrap grid system and then let's add
two columns to our section here and then
we'll add an inline form a horizontal
form and then just a default vertical
form so to kind of showcase three of the
different forms you can use inside of
bootstrap so the first thing let's go
ahead and do is we're going to get a
container so we're gonna say div class
equals container
and the containers in bootstrap sort of
act as you know kind of your main outer
element that you can wrap things inside
of rows and columns and things like that
they have fixed with containers and they
also have fluids stretchy containers and
then inside of our container we're going
to set up a two columns so here we're
gonna say div whoops class equals and
here we can say row so we're gonna be
setting up an initial row and inside of
this row we can say div class equals
call and then you can see all the
presets here inside of bootstrap so
bootstrap is based on a twelve column
grid by default and it uses flexbox to
create this grid behind the scenes but
you can you can specify like if I want
two columns that are equal width they
would each take up six so you can think
of like called - six would basically be
half width and then another call - six
would be another half width so let's go
ahead and add this one first we're gonna
say call - six and I'll just call this
first column and then inside of this
initial top row let's go ahead and add
another one so we're gonna say div class
equals called - six
so we'll say second column okay so let's
go ahead and save here and we're going
to refresh here this page and make it go
to our slash we call this forms HTML and
you can see here now in this basic page
over here I have a first column over
here in a second column over here and as
I resize the page these columns are
always staying equal width meaning this
one is taking up six out of twelve
columns and this one is taking up six
out of twelve columns so just to kind of
illustrate this let's go ahead and
switch this grid here I'm just gonna
rescale this a little bit let's change
this to call - three and call - nine
it's always a good idea when you're
working within a single row when you're
working with columns they should add up
to 12
so 9 plus 3 is 12 because 12 is means a
full width so let's go ahead and save
this and then we can come over here and
refresh
and now you can see that this first
column is only taking up three twelfths
of the space and the second column here
is taking up nine twelfths of the space
so that's kind of how you work with the
columns inside of a row if I want to add
another row down below you simply can
just copy this entire row code and drop
it right down below and now essentially
I'm going to have a 2x2 grid two rows
and two columns in each row so let's
save that we'll just call this one third
and we'll call the last one fourth and
let's go ahead and save and refresh and
now you can see I've got that 2x2 grid
up there now the bootstrap columns are
responsive by a default so bootstrap has
that built in so if we do an inspect
element over here and just move into our
responsive mode I'm just gonna
illustrate how we can change the width
here and you will watch those columns
automatically resize so as my viewport
gets down you can see those columns kind
of jumping around resizing themselves
and then eventually we get down here to
the mobile and you know that's kind of
what it looks like
now if you don't specify a media
breakpoint modifier the columns will
always be three and nine you can see
even all the way down on mobile view
they're not splitting into a stacked
view so if you want them to split we
need to change and add some media
responsive breakpoints and that's really
simple to do in bootstrap you just add a
small medium or large
to your class names so for example on
this first one let's call this call -
medium - three MD for medium and we'll
call this one call - medium - nine now
let's go ahead and save and refresh and
first I just want to illustrate this so
you can watch what happens so you can
see right now this is taking up there
they're behaving correctly and then as
soon as I get below the medium
breakpoint you can see now they stack on
top of one another this first and second
column so the way the breakpoints work
is column medium three means
medium and above will behave in three
columns once it gets below a medium then
they stack
so that's kind of what the way that
works so let's change this second row
down here to call - large - three and
we'll call this one called s large let's
actually make this one down here six and
six just to illustrate that you don't
have to have them be the same in each
row each row can be completely different
so you can see here on the large this
one is taking up half and this one's
taking a path that's a 3 & a 9
as I come below large the second row now
stacks because I got below that large
break point and as I get below medium
now the first row now stacks as well so
that's just kind of a little primer into
the way the grid works inside of
bootstrap you can sort of customize the
grid and you can move things all over
the place but that's the basics of just
working with rows and columns so fairly
straightforward to do so what we're
going to do now is we're just gonna make
all these six I'm just gonna have four
equal and I'm gonna make them all medium
so medium and above they will lay out
horizontally medium and below they will
all stack on top of one another so now
we have those sort of grid elements in
place there so instead of saying first
column second column etc we're going to
replace the first column over here with
an actual form so let's start out and
we'll just add in a form just we're just
going to leave this whoops we're just
going to leave this as a default form
tag here and let's add in a simple form
so a form we know has an input so let's
give this input a type of text and we'll
just give it a name of username and that
should work just fine and we'll give it
an ID let's pull this over just a little
bit so we can see this an ID of username
as well okay now forms typically have
labels so let's give this guy a label
and we'll call it the user name and
we'll say 4 equals user name so that
this label is attached to its element
whoops looks like I have an extra hole
there we go extra bracket in there at
so you can see now I have this little
element and that's looking fine now
bootstrap has several classes for
working with forms that make them line
up and display a little bit easier and
the first one is an option or a class
name is Kai called call group so let's
take a look at that
so we're gonna come over here inside of
our former we're gonna wrap this input
inside of a div that has the class of
form group I said call group but it's
called the form group okay so we create
that div and then we can just cut this
guy out and paste him right inside of
there and we'll save and refresh so that
will create the form group class whoops
and we're gonna do one more so let's go
ahead and let's actually back take these
a little bit let's just copy this entire
form group we're going to paste it right
below but this one down here is going to
be instead of a label for username let's
just call this one password and we'll
say 4 equals password here and then the
text we'll just say is password password
and we'll go ahead and save and refresh
so now we have our username and we have
our password and those are looking just
fine
now you'll notice that there's really
not a lot of styling happening on these
in fact they're not even lined up
properly and that's because we still
need to add one more class called form
control to our actual inputs so let's
come down here to the input we're gonna
give this guy a class of form control
and the same thing down here class
equals form control and we'll save and
refresh and now you can see they get a
little bit of styling built into him by
default and they automatically line up
nicely for us okay the last thing we're
going to add here is we're just going to
copy this entire bit one more time paste
it down below and we're going to call
this one will will delete the label
because this one's just going to be a
submit button
we'll go ahead and delete the input and
we'll replace it with just a button and
it's gonna have the class of BTN and BTN
- primary and then we'll just call this
submit and we'll save here and refresh
you can see that now adds in a submit
button right below our column there now
these two options are also bootstrap
classes so this is giving the class of
button and then we have what style of
button is a secondary one so we have
button primary we have button secondary
there's all sorts of different color
classes that bootstrap has where you can
change the buttons we can say button -
large whoops
BTN - small or BTN - large to make small
and large variants of these buttons we
can do outlines and things like that so
anyway we'll just leave this back here
at our primary button for now folks
let's change this to primary okay so
that's just the basic form that's just a
typical stacked horizontal form where
the labels are above the inputs and our
form over here we're going to do the
exact same thing except our labels are
going to be to the left of the inputs
okay in order to do that we're going to
copy all of this form we just ready
build and paste it down into the second
column here let's just save and refresh
here so we can see that now in order to
get our labels over on the left we
essentially are going to be leveraging
bootstraps grid system to make our
labels take up two columns and our value
our input fields to take up ten columns
so you can you can nest the bootstrap
grid so I can have a container in a row
and I can have a sixth column box and
inside of that six column box I can
create another full grid and you know do
columns and rows inside of there so you
can have nested grids inside of grids
with the bootstrap grid just fine so
let's go ahead and take a look at that
so in order to get this to work the one
thing we need to do is we give our label
a class so we're gonna say class equals
and then we just call this guy like
basically give it whatever column you
want so we're gonna say call - small - -
okay so let's save and refresh here so
you can see that that's going to take up
two columns and then we need to wrap the
input field here in another row so we're
gonna say div class equals call - not
not row a column call - small - tin okay
and then we'll just close this guy off
after whoops it's getting a little bit
tricky to see there and then let's
refresh here and let's pull this up so
we can kind of see this okay and then we
also need to give to our form group when
extra class as well here because our
form group is going to act as a row so
we're gonna also give it the class of
row so now we can refresh here and you
can see now those are laying out a side
by side inside of that area so this of
course is squish down too much you can
see that there we go you can kind of see
that so now they're laid laying side by
side now you can notice it's a little
bit subtle but the user name is actually
at the top it's aligned at the top of
the input we want this guy in the middle
and in order to do that we have to give
one more class to our label which is
called -
- label now let's save and refresh here
and you can see what that does it just
centers it up so it's in the middle of
that form over there so now we just need
to apply all the same things to the
second one so we'll just take this down
here we'll take this entire class for
the label we'll paste it down here as
well and then we'll take this div and
we'll wrap this input in a div as well
just like we did before and save and
refresh over here
there we go so now those are laying out
side by side and in this one down here
we probably want to our submit button
maybe over here right we want to kind of
have a blank space right there
we're going to do is we're going to
follow the same process we did before
we're gonna come down to this div we
have our button inside of we're gonna
give it a row so it acts as a wrapper
and then we're going to wrap this button
in a div so we'll say div class equals
call - small - 10 so it's gonna be
taking up 10 units there and again we'll
cut this guy out paste him inside of
there okay and what we can do now is we
can use a property called offset so we
can say offset - small - - and you'll
see when I save and refresh here watch
this guy jump right over here so offset
what that means is it's going to offset
those 10 columns over to columns so now
we essentially have a blank column here
and then this guy starts over there so
that's pretty easy way of doing that so
now we have the two methods we have the
stacked one we have the width one with
the labels on the left and then down
here let's just merge these two together
and we're going to be doing an inline
form so instead of having two columns
down here on our row let's just delete
this one and let's just make this one a
call medium actually it's not really
going to matter we can just say call 12
in this one and it'll be a full width
column you can see like so so let's kind
of pull this guy down a little bit
because we're just going to be kind of
paying attention to this third column
here that looks pretty good
okay so let's add the final in line form
let's go ahead and copy pasta just like
we did before copy paste so we're gonna
copy all that form code there and we're
gonna paste it down into this twelve
column element and refresh so there we
go and in order to create a form that's
in line you come to your main form and
you give it a class that's called form
dash in line and we'll save and refresh
here and you can see that just
automatically converts things to be in
line the one thing I do need to do is
with the form in line we don't
necessarily need all these form groups
and rows because that was for our last
sample so we can delete all of those
guys
let's see that guy that guy so we just
have our labels save and refresh their
up side to leave too much oh I still
need my form groups whoops let's undo
that undo that undo undo undo so the
thing I need to delete is the rose so we
don't need separate rows for each one
and then down here on this button we
don't need to have this guy offset
anymore as well so now let's save and
refresh there okay something's still
happening here oh yeah I still have
these set up is this is from the
previous example so I've got to go
remove all that stuff we just pretty
added so we can delete we can delete
that we can delete this because they're
not they're not taking up columns 10 and
2 anymore so let's clean all that up and
refresh
okay so that's looking pretty close
there
so we can now go ahead and remove these
form groups as before we don't need any
of them so let's save and refresh all
that you can see it's laying out the
same and you can see there's little bit
of padding and whatnot issues in inline
forms we could solve that by wrapping
them in the grid but we don't want to do
that I'm gonna illustrate one other
feature of bootstrap which is its
ability to add padding and margins to
any elements with just class names so we
can come up for example to our user name
so let's actually back take these a
little bit so we can see this a little
bit better so on the label itself in the
class I can give this guy some you can
say padding so P is for padding and you
can see they have five levels p1 through
five so if I see if I say padding - five
and save and refresh you can see that
adds five units of padding around that
helmand so you can also say PR for
padding - right top bottom PBP RPL you
can save px which means the x-axis you
can say py which means the y-axis the
top and bottom and are left on the right
so you can add all sorts of modifier
keys to just the padding so I'm gonna
say PR - one and save and refresh here
and you can see that just adds a little
bit of padding there on the left and you
can sort of tweak padding tweak all
those things to adjust your form
elements just how you want the issues
you see here is our submit buttons
actually come down to another line and
that's because we still have all these
form labels that we added from our
previous sample - so we can go ahead and
delete those when you're working with
inline forms you don't need a lot of
additional classes you can just kind of
almost have vanilla inputs and labels
and they'll work sort of as you expect
so there we go nice and over where it's
supposed to so I can come down here to
my password and for this one let's give
it a class whoops P X so it's gonna be
on the left and right of one and we'll
refresh that and you can see how that
adds on the left and right and then on
our submit button here - we'll do the
same thing of
P X - 1 or something so you could use
all those different padding classes now
you can also do margins so P is for
padding M is for margins which is the
outside right of the box model so and
the same modifiers work for either one
so there is our final form so we have
three different forms we have our top
one our left one and our bottom one all
built three different ways and bootstrap
and they're all fully responsive and
behave it and work really well so that's
all we're going to do for our forms page
let's jump now over and create our
second page which is going to be for our
tables so we're going to come back over
here to vs code and we'll create a new
file inside of our demo folder and this
one's going to be tables dot HTML
and the same thing like we did before
let's just actually come to our forums
we'll say command a we'll come over here
and command V to paste and let's go
ahead and delete everything inside of
our body we'll leave our container
because we're gonna need that so we'll
kind of delete all this stuff there we
go so we just have another container
again inside of our body tag and this
time let's come over here and change
this to tables whoops and hit return so
now I have a blank empty document to
work with these tables now you may be
wondering why did I show you all this
bootstrap stuff if I haven't even shown
you where you can get and install and
work with the bootstrap documentation so
let's take a look at that the website is
bootstrap get bootstrap calm and I
wanted you to just get your hands wet a
little bit with bootstrap before you so
you can kind of see how those classes
and whatnot work before you dive deep
into the documentation the documentation
is a little bit overwhelming because
there's just a lot to learn with
bootstrap but you come over to get
bootstrap calm and you can download the
full source here and play around with it
but what you really want to do is come
over here to the documentation tab and
it has fairly good search so if you want
to work with tables you can just come
over here and type tables and hit return
there and it will just pull up all the
various code for the tables all the
different classes that modify tables and
the different looks and fills of tables
you can see you hear that bootstrap is a
utility framework because almost
everything in bootstrap is controlled
and modified with CSS class names so
adding table Styles just like we added
form Styles it's all done with class
names you rarely go in and edit the
source of course we're going to be doing
that in part three but most people will
just use class names to sort of you know
customize and tweak and move things
around as they're needed so this is
where you can come and read about how
table code works and play around with
all this various the various options so
rather than typing all the table code
out by hand we're actually going to use
some copy-paste here from the
documentation so we're gonna come down
here and we're going to start with the
option called table head options and
we're gonna copy all of this table code
from this example here and the only
reason we're doing this here is mainly
so we can kind of see
how'd they look by default and then if
we decide to do any overrides later on
we can kind of compare our overrides
with the default bootstrap styles so I'm
just copying this first table here let's
come over to the container and we will
paste and let's just save that and I'll
back over here to our page and refresh
so here we have a basic table I'll just
go over a couple of these class names
quick but you can see here that you just
give it the class of table and if you
have a tea head element you can give
various classes so I can say tea head
dark I can say tea headlight let's save
and refresh that and I can also use the
various color classes so I can say like
primary or secondary or blue or pink and
all that sort of different stuff so you
can color these guys various ways oh I
guess warning mourning doesn't work on
that so we'll go back to dark because
that one was working fine there and you
can see that this by default here the
table is getting some lines and that's
because we have the class of table on
the main table element if I take that
off and save and refresh here you can
see we just get a default hold HTML
table so just a couple of properties
here on this guy I'm gonna leave this
table as default and then I'm gonna grab
this table and I'm gonna copy it and
paste it down below to add just another
exact copy of it so we're gonna have two
tables here now on this one here let's
change the table we're gonna call this
table - bordered and I'll save and
refresh and you can see that that's
going to add a border all the way around
also I'm going to add an option called
table - striped and that's going to make
every other row alternated down have
alternating colors which is helpful to
read if you have a lot of data right
when you're scanning through a table and
then lastly on this guy I'm gonna show
you one thing you can do you can add an
extra div here as a wrapper element and
on this wrapper you can give it the
class of table - responsive and what
this means I'm going to make this
closing tag close after the last table
and save and refresh if your browser is
smaller than the width of the table this
is a common problem tables are tricky to
deal with on
mobile devices but if my browser is
smaller so let's come down here and pull
this under table - responsive gives you
this slider you can see my top table
doesn't get that it's actually truncated
the data I can't even see there's more
table data over there in less I
horizontal scroll the entire page but by
adding that table - responsive wrapper
you allow the users to in line be able
to scroll back and forth and see the
additional table data which is kind of a
nice little feature so that's a really
easy way to make your tables responsive
by just wrapping them with that single
div so there's a couple of tables I'm
just gonna show you here in the
documentation you can add colors you can
add alternating row stripes this is the
one we just pretty looked at dark tables
light tables down here at the very very
bottom here you can see they have color
variations for row success danger
warning you just add those on the table
row classic self so if I want this table
row here I can say class equals table -
success and now when I come back here
and refresh my form that guy gets
highlighted with the success which is
green by default in bootstrap so there's
all sorts of ways you can tweak and
color tables and the documentation is
really well done here so you can kind of
read through that so that's really all
we're gonna do on our tables page our
third and final page we're going to be
setting up here Before we jump into the
third part of this tutorial is setting
up a page we're gonna call cards this
could be used for like widgets or little
elements but we're just gonna call it
cards so let's come over here and we're
gonna create one more page in our demo
new file let's call this cards HTML just
like we did before let's copy all the
code for tables and we'll just paste it
in the cards here delete everything
inside of our container and save okay so
let's come over here and move over to
cards so cards where a concept that was
introduced in bootstrap for they didn't
exist in bootstrap 3 they're kind of
like bootstrap threes Wells they had
this thing called well cards are kind of
a fancier version of Wells I suppose but
they're really really nice you can do
some really cool things with cards
actually like them a lot I use them
quite often
I'm working with bootstrap so the card
elements let's come over here to the
documentation you can just hit cards
here and you can really do a lot with
cards so cards basically have three
basic parts there's a top which they
call a card header there's the body
which is the card body and the bottom is
called the card footer so you can add
images you can do all sorts of things
you can stack them do columns with them
but I just want to show you a basic card
here so I'm gonna come down here we go
so this one where's one with the footer
here I'm just scrolling down there we go
so here's one that has a header you can
see this is the card header this is the
card body and then this is the card
footer so let's go ahead and just copy
this code actually let's just type this
out because cards I think a worthwhile
to kind of see how they work so what's
cool about cards is we can place them
inside of a grid to create some
interesting elements so the first thing
is let's create a div which is class of
row and then let's create two columns so
we're gonna say div class equals call -
six and then let's just go ahead and
copy this and place it down below here
and we'll just make sure this is working
we'll call it someone we'll call this
one to come over here and refresh okay
so that's working fine whoops we have
both of our columns our left and right
columns here and now inside of these
columns we can add some content so
inside of our first column here let's
add a card so for a card you say div
class equals card and then wait for the
header you can say div class equals card
- header like so and then you can add a
header so maybe I'm going to add an H
let's do an h2 of card title
okay below the header we have a div of
class equals card - body and this is the
card body and then lastly we have a div
class equals card - footer whoops and
this guy
oops I missed the angle bracket there I
think I just double out of it yep is our
footer okay so we're gonna save and
refresh here and you can kind of see how
those guys layout by default so they
work pretty fancy there we just have our
basic card so let's go ahead and just do
a little bit of lorem ipsum here so
we'll just save that so you can kind of
see what that looks like with a bit more
information there and then also let's
copy all of this card code and paste it
into our second column and save and
refresh and you can see there's our next
card now I'm going to duplicate both of
these rows so I'm going to grab each of
these rows and copy and paste so we're
gonna have a 2x2 grid of cards you can
see how these different cards in there
so that is looking fine here whoops I
copied I didn't add a row so I'm
actually gonna undo that here I've got
to add my row starts there so I need
this guy as well so I need to add
another row and this will fix that
little margin and padding it you just
really saw in the preview so let's save
that and refresh there we go so now
they're the equal you can see they're
equal widths before they were a little
bit
squee juanpis okay so cards you can see
they lay out fairly easily
now with this sample here I'm actually
going to change my container so I want
this to be a fluid container just to
illustrate kind of another feature here
bootstrap so instead of container I'm
gonna say container - whoops container -
fluid watch what happens when i refresh
here you can see now it stretches all
the way to the edge of my viewport when
I resize here like so now again we can
use the responsive classes on bootstrap
if I wanted to move these guys down or
up these cards down here I could come
down to this second row of cards and I
could give this class a card of margin
top - three let's see what that looks
like there we go and you can go all the
way to four or five right if I want to
try to make the gutter match the gutter
here it's all the way up to five that
way they're gonna kind of look fairly
similar but you can play with those guys
how you want
just lost my place there we are so I'll
give that one a margin top of four I'll
give this one down here a margin top of
four is well whoops I give the wrong one
and margin top before that one and
oops I gave this one the wrong one let's
save and refresh now I'm getting myself
confused here so I need my second row my
two on my second row so they're down
here there we go
so that one and that one should each
have a margin top there we go and now
they're pushed down properly and you can
add buttons you can add forms inside of
cards you can really do anything you
want with cards you can customize the
colors with the SAS files when we if you
want to override those you can see and
the documentation here you can even do
colors clear down here at the bottom
they have some info on colors so if you
wanted to colorize them you can just use
the BG properties so let's take a look
at that really quick so maybe I want
this card title to be a different one
so we'll come up here to the header and
say BG - primary BG for background and
we'll give it our primary color
background anyway all sorts of things
you can do with cards we can change the
color of the text of there we can say
text - white that'll make the text white
on that background that's a little of
course hard to read you wouldn't to do
that you can see just how far you can
customize and take these cards you can
make them flow with you can use the grid
anyway
really really cool so that's the card
element in bootstrap really helpful for
doing things as far as messages and
whatnot
so that is our three basic pages of
bootstrap we have our forms we have our
tables we have our cards I just want to
illustrate two more things that are
common in bootstrap things but we're not
going to create dedicated pages for them
I'm just gonna show you in the bootstrap
documentation and those are buttons the
button element and the warning or
dialogue elements so I'm just gonna come
over here and show you the button group
so buttons like we already use this
button before but you just give the
class of button followed by the modifier
where there's a primary secondary
success danger warning so those will
give you all your different levels of
buttons so you can make them big small
you can do drop-down buttons
block buttons you can see you can really
take buttons and do quite a bit with
them you can do group buttons like this
which are kind of like radios for
different elements so buttons are very
common thing the second one is the
alerts so alerts also come in the
standard colors so you can have your
success warning danger info secondary
primary alerts they even have
dismissible alerts if you tailor them
with JavaScript but by default you just
give them a class of alert and then the
color of the alert that automatically
gives them a border a background color
and it changed the text to match the
text of the alert color as well so
that's what you do with alerts down here
you can see there's a couple options I
believe they have yet here's a
dismissable alert so you can click the X
and it actually dismisses the alert
which is helpful for an action that pops
up if a user clicks you know save record
you want to pop something up that says
success and I can go ahead and just
dismiss that alert as well so those are
alerts kind of in conjunction with
alerts are a thing that bootstrap calls
modal's mo D ALS so a modal is like an
alert basically that's intrusive so it's
going to pop up above everything on the
page and require an action from the user
that is dismissible so a modal down here
you can see this is a modal right it's
going to pop up in front of your page so
watch this so when you click a modal you
can see it animates down the background
gets a little bit of a demo
and then you can read the thing and you
can dismiss it or you can you know do
whatever you want here of course but
that's what bootstrap calls a modal it's
an intrusive alert basically is the way
I like to think about them so those are
just the last couple things I wanted to
illustrate quickly on the bootstrap
documentation we could have a 20-hour
course just on bootstrap really because
there's just a lot to learn but that's a
few of the basics and setting up some
bootstrap grids working with a few of
the elements learning about those
classes in the grid system and next in
part three of this tutorial we're now
going to build our custom wrapper
or a custom admin theme around bootstrap
brute strap does have the ability to
create math bars so nav bars that
automatically will respond and give you
a drop down menu on mobile but they're a
little bit limited and when most people
create admin themes they actually don't
use the built-in bootstrap nav system
they kind of create their own one thing
bootstrap doesn't have which we're going
to build is what we call an off canvas
menu where the menu slides in and out
from the side on a mobile view that's
not possible to do with native bootstrap
so what you'll see is most people end up
building those by hand and then sort of
putting bootstrap in the middle of their
app but the actual skeleton the menu the
sidebars and whatnot are custom created
and that's exactly the method we're
going to take as well so come join and
in part three and let's take a look at
that
so let's go ahead and start with the
coat here so I'm gonna pull up my notes
there's quite about HTML that will add
but the good news is once we get all the
HTML in here we can't leave it alone we
don't need touch it so we are going to
add a couple of classes on our body so
we're gonna say class equals app and
sidebar - Minnie this is going to enable
this mini sidebar you can either disable
or enable this with this little toggle
and then we're gonna add in a header and
then we're gonna add in a unordered list
so ul and it's going to have 1 2 list
items so we're gonna say Li times 2 and
the first one the UL is gonna have a
class of app - nav and the list item is
going to have a class of the first one
anyway app - search
the second one is going to have a class
of drop-down this is gonna be a
bootstrap drop down here in just a
minute wait let's save and see what that
looks like
there we go so there's both of theirs I
guess when you save the HTML because
it's the distribution it's not hot
reloading but that's fine okay and we're
also going to be adding in here into our
header element the anchor tag so we're
gonna have an anchor and it's going to
have an H ref equals just pain this is
gonna be our HQ admins it's gonna be our
title essentially in our navbar
and this guy is going to have a class of
app - header and then it's the logo
element
so we'll save that and refresh that over
there you can see that
we're gonna be adding our sidebar toggle
in here in just a minute this guy
actually needs to come back one space
okay so that is it for those two inside
of our drop-down we need to add in a few
links
so our drop-down item is going to have
an icon so here we can finally test this
out
I'm just double-checking my notes
there's so much code I'm skipping over
quite a bit of code because I don't just
want to go start from finish I kind of
want to build this in pieces so you can
kind of see how it's built so I'm trying
to skip back and forth a little bit so
let's add an anchor tag
so right here inside of our first
drop-down we're going to be adding an
anchor tag and this anchor tag is going
to have the class of app - nav
item
like so and it's gonna have an H ref
that's just empty it's going to have a
data - toggle which is going to be set
to drop down and we're gonna do an
aria-label or accessibility here it's
gonna be set to open open one menu sure
and then we're going to close off that
anchor tag now inside of the anchor tag
I'm going to turn on my line wrapping
here cuz it's getting a little crazy
oops wrong key inside of the S code here
inside of the sinker tag we're gonna add
an icon so icon class now we're finally
gonna test out our font awesome so fa fa
- search and then close off whoops that
icon and save and let's refresh oh sweet
so font awesome is working correctly so
there's our little search icon so when
we click on this it's going to toggle
the we actually don't want this one if
they search I like we want this one as
the person which is like fa - user I
think FA - large let's refresh that
there we go
so when we click on this guy it's going
to drop down our drop down menu for us
so now let's add the drop down menu and
that's gonna be added as an unordered
list right inside here let's actually do
this UL li x 3 and each of those
Pinker's is gonna have an anchor tag
okay whoops the UL didn't work don't
know what I did
oh well so let's just manually get that
unordered list I'm gonna move the turtle
down here a little bit close the
unordered list to have all these guys at
worst you can see those
so our unordered list is gonna have the
class of drop-down - menu and the it's
gonna be our settings menu and the
drop-down - menu - right this will be on
the right side our page
and then each of these list items have
an anchor tag and these anchor tags are
going to have the classes class equals
drop down - item and we'll just call
this one like something we'll just give
all these anchor tags some text for just
a minute and refresh
and it's working look at that so this is
the bootstrap drop-down so when I click
this I'm getting my drop-down menu to
fly down inside of here now we need to
add these classes in
to these guys as well that styles them a
bit prettier so they have the drop down
items and refresh so there we can toggle
out that little drop-down let's add some
font awesome icons in these Pinker tags
as well so icon class equals fa fa - cog
we'll say on this guy
and then close the icon let's copy that
and paste it into we're gonna do a space
right there paste that one into there
and that went into there so we'll have a
cog we'll have a user or something and
we'll have a this one's called sign -
out - alt so now we can refresh and see
these so there's our three icons some
settings or something right sign out so
maybe we'll call this one logout call
that one a profile and we'll call this
one the settings refresh over here you
can see our little drop-down looking
pretty lovely there so that's working
fine now on our drop-down menu so that's
pretty much it for our header we have
our title we have a search inside of
this search we're going to actually add
in an input because we actually want a
search bar so an input type class this
as app - search and then it's going to
be our input the type here whoops
type is going to be set to the search
type that's the html5 search type the
new input type and H ref actually only
an H on this will say data - no let's
see placeholder that's what I'm looking
for placeholder text is going to be set
to search and that should be fine for
the input let's see what that looks like
there's a little search bar perfect and
then we'll add in a button it'll give
this the class of app - search
underscore button this is all these CSS
rules I'm adding here all are we're
going to be using custom C of this so
this is not bootstrap CSS we're going to
be writing this CSS to sort of tailor
this to our needs we could easily use
bootstrap code as well but we're going
to
bootstrap code later so there's our
button and we'll close the button off
and we will add an icon here so another
icon fa whoops class
close the icon act class equals fa fa -
search
and save and refresh there we go now
we've got our little search bar over
there so in other words we can type in
here and then click that search button
and make something happen
well of course style that on our own
here in a minute and that's most of the
code there for our header so quite a bit
of code but we'll be styling this a
little bit later with some CSS and now
let's just add a couple of other little
pieces here for our sidebar so we're
gonna have some CSS we're gonna have our
sidebar and we're going to have our
content so let's go ahead new the
sidebar first so div class equals half -
sidebar okay there's that and it's going
to have an unordered list
ul
hello times I don't know however many
things we want there five I guess
they'll all have dinger tags as well so
that looks pretty okay for that
and this ul is going to have the class
of app - menu
and we're going to have
yeah that that looks actually fine
instead of a div we could use a side
here because it's technically a side bar
so let's move might as well use our
html5 tags call that a side AB side bar
app menu not a whole buncha leaks that
we'll be doing with our menu items so
we'll save and refresh that nothing in
these for right now but we'll just see
test a whole bunch of times
test test test test test there we go and
then now that we have that side done we
can come down here and add our main
element so our main is going to have the
class of app - content oops I said min
supposed to be main
tap content and it's going to have a div
that has the class of app title and then
underneath app title we are going to
have
any other content rows and stuff like
that so we'll just say div class equals
row so this is the bootstrap grid system
here div class equals call - medium -
six so maybe we'll have a row with two
columns this one will be a left column
this one over here will be a right
column let's save and refresh so you can
see on medium there we're getting the
left and right and when we go down to a
mobile view it automatically stacks so
bootstrap grid is doing that for us so
there's the grid system coming into play
and that's that's pretty much it so you
know we can flesh out our main area
however we want
now the CSS we're gonna add is just
going to be to take the header and make
a header bar get our left sidebar over
on the left and the other column over
there on the right and when we'll be off
to the races so let's go ahead and do
that okay let's start off here in the
header section so we can start to flash
a little bit of this code out so we're
gonna move over into our app header as
CSS file and let's go ahead and go a
little bit of this we're gonna say dot
app header I'm going to be writing some
sass in here so this isn't just pure CSS
the sass and we're gonna say
position:fixed because we want our
header to stay at the top left 0 right 0
bottom 0 and width 100% so that's a bit
of a trick that's going to make it so
that our header stretches all the way
across power HTML so files we want to
kind of have handy here
so we kind of go back forth and
double-check we can turn this one off we
can turn this one off for a minute we
can turn that one off turn that one off
we'll have our index there we go so this
is going to be our tap header now inside
of our header tag itself we need to give
this guy a class that I didn't give
before so class equals PAP - header and
we can save that and refresh and you can
see right away our header disappears
because we add a bit of that CSS - it's
just over there so let's now come back
to our header and add some more sass
code to this guy
okay so with one under percent we're
gonna also say display flex because
there's several items in our header you
know we want those guys to be displayed
in using the Flex box model and we're
gonna give a background color here just
using red for now just so we can kind of
see that you can see our header is there
it's just down there at the very bottom
and that's because bottom zero is
supposed to be top zero I couldn't see
that I was I wasn't even looking at the
bottom of my screen there we go so you
can see now it's display flex my logo
and my search bar and my dis guy right
here or whatever we call that her
drop-down they're starting to lay out a
little bit differently so that's working
okay and we're gonna give this guy a Z
dash index of Happ 1050 just because
we're gonna be pushing and pulling some
things we want to make sure it stays in
the front okay and let's go ahead and
also give us some padding right of 15
pixels so that's looking okay there
all right so each of these three
elements should be children of our app
header so notice we have the app header
so our anchor tag is the first child the
unordered list is the second child and
it's the thing that has those two to
inside of us who are eventually going to
take these guys and also make those go
side by side in our app nav in a minute
but that will do it for that so instead
of a background color here we're gonna
replace this with a variable we're gonna
call this our primary color our primary
color in hex now that variable doesn't
exist so we're gonna have to open up our
variables tab and create it so primary -
hex and we'll just set that to red for
now just so we can make sure it's
working properly and let's come back to
our app header what did I call it
primary - hex is set to red
and that's set to primary hex but it's
not working there so something is not
compiling down in our variables oh I
think I know the issue so we have to
come back to our main CSS file and make
sure we're importing our ab header oh we
are we're importing our variables first
which is what we want then we're
importing our app header so that should
be working
um oh where is that app header go let's
close to title here we go
let's close this sidebar and the
sidewalk mini our variables there we go
I put that inside of quotes I was
treating as a string but you can't do
that with SAS variables so now we're
back in business
for our variable here so we're gonna
declare specific colors here for these
so our primary hex color I'm gonna look
here in my notes and see what color I
have set so 0 0 a 0 0 0 and a 0 FF and
again you can use whatever colors you
want this is just a color scheme I'm
going with so this should give a bright
blue yep there we go that works and
that'll be fine for now
ok back to our header so let's go ahead
and add in a little bit more CSS we're
going to design up our logo so this is
the app - header logo and we're going to
give this guy a flex of 1-0 Auto like so
and we are going to say color is white
so FFF
and that did not turn white so I must
not have this class so app header
underscore logo let's go to our index
and make sure we do that app - header
underscore underscore logo
Oh whoops I did a I did an ID instead of
class we need to do a dot there there we
go
so now you can see that works out okay
and let's see where were we so we're
gonna change the font family so the font
family is going to be set to whatever
our font family is so I call this my app
- font - serif now this doesn't exist
yet so we gotta come over here we have
to create that so we'll call this our
pop - font - serif and this is gonna be
whatever you want your fonts to be so I
create two fonts I have a serif font and
a sans serif font so it's kind of up to
you what you want to do there so this
one's going to be we're just gonna say
it this is not a serif font but well
let's just just say Times and then for
the we're gonna copy this and we're
gonna say sands - serif so tap font sans
serif will call verdana just to set
those two up okay so now when we save
this you can see our font they're just
updated to that new font which is the
Times New Roman but of course we would
swap those out for whatever we want okay
let's see next we are going to add in
text-align:center and we're going to
give a font size of twenty six pixels
we're going to give some padding of zero
on the top and bottom and 15 on the left
and right
make sure : there so that's looking okay
line-height this is gonna really depend
on your font as well but let's set it to
50 pixels on mine and that should be
okay for now
so there we have our logo or our title
whatever you want to call that guy
all right now let's work on the search
and the search button up there so we're
gonna say dot app - search we're gonna
set that position to relative relative
display as Flex aligned self-center
margin right margin right at 15 pixels
padding we're just gonna leave that
alone for a minute actually and that'll
do fine there
so the app search again is going to be
up in where is that absurd shop inside
here so that's the list item itself now
we're going to be doing the input and
the button so the app search input is
going to be next and it's going to have
a border so we're getting rid of all
that default stuff of zero we kind of
watch this update over here as I'm
saving and we're gonna give us some
padding 5 pixels 10 pixels
Oh
patting - right we're going to get
override and make 30 pixels border -
radius to round the corners of two
pixels background - color we're gonna
make our GBA and we're gonna make it Oh
255 255 255 point eight for our opacity
or alpha value so now you can see it's
kind of semi-transparent inside of here
right this blue background is glowing
going through I don't know if that's
shining through transparent seen through
and that should do it for that we could
change the placeholder color we can add
some transitions we can do all sorts of
stuff there but we'll call that good so
next we're gonna be doing our app -
search app search button itself so for
this guy we're gonna say
position:absolute go on write 0 and we
want padding actually we want top 10
pixels we want the padding to be zero on
the top and then ten on the left and
right turn off all the borders all
together let's say that and see what
that does so that looks pretty good
we're gonna make the color the same as
no actually we're not we're gonna make
the color another rgba 0 0 0.8 for the
color
and no background because we don't want
that little see how there's a little
background right there I'm going to turn
that off and there we go so you can type
inside of here and then you can just
click that search button and it kind of
integrates right into the element with
an icon one thought some icon pretty
cool so that's pretty much all we need
to do there we can also set the cursor
cursor cursor to pointer and that way
when we hover over this guy we get the
pointer cursor instead of the default
cursor all right that will do it for the
search and the logo so we still have to
lay these guys out a little bit better
and we have to kind of fix this little
drop down so we want this to kind of
appear right over at the side of there
but that will mostly get us where we
need to be so now let's work on this
sidebar and then just a few final
touches and then we'll finish up this
tutorial we could of course wait I mean
we could go for eons we could do this
for 12 hours straight so we're near the
end so let's go ahead and do that okay
so we're going to do the sidebar next so
let's go ahead and open up our app you
can see I've got my apps sidebar a sass
file ready to go and we will add in some
stuff for this guy so first thing is
first is we're going to add a rule here
for the app - sidebar and it's going to
have a position of fixed that's going to
be top:0 left:0 left 0 bottom zero
we're gonna give a little bit of padding
on the top because we don't want
elements running right up against the
top of this and so we're gonna give it
70 pixels now that's also going to make
it so that our Elma some go underneath
our header up their navbar you can see
that push down all of those elements
right there so that's what that did for
us and we're gonna give this guy a width
of 230 pixels or something now in an
ideal world we'd also make this with the
CSS variable that way we could easily
change the width of our sidebar later on
and we are going to set the overflow to
auto we're going to give it some z-index
of something like 10 or something just
so it gets pushed in front and we're
going to give it a background color and
this we are going to be using as CSS
variable for so we're gonna say sidebar
- color and that sidebar color we're
going to declare in our variables file
right here right now
so the sidebar color that I have chosen
is going to be
well although shattering sidebar - color
and that's going to equal
to
a 4f 6 9 it's kind of a dark blue so
there we go now and we save this you can
see now we've got her dark side bar
color over there which looks great
and let's keep going here on this little
guy
pull back up my notes
okay and we're gonna give this guy a
Bach shadow because it's gonna have a
little shadow kind of poking out over
there to the right so it's gonna be zero
pixels and then eight pixels and
seventeen pixels that's the amount of
blur rgba again and it's going to be
well that's kind of weird I didn't know
it's gonna head
all of those for me zero zero zero comma
and then
point two
you
like so so that adds just a little bit
you really can't see it but it has a
little bit of a shadow layer over on the
right side of the sidebar so that's what
that did for us
and that will be that
you
next we're gonna kind of tweak these
menu items a little bit so let's go
ahead and do those guys so we're gonna
say app whoops dot app - menu underscore
underscore item now we actually I got a
double check to see if we have
there are menu items that came here if
we added those on our navigation we did
not so we need to come in to our actual
sidebar items and on these anchor tags
they need to be menu items so we need to
add those so on each of these anchor
tags they're going to have the class of
app - menu underscore underscore item
well-liked so there are menu could
support drop-down so a secondary tier as
well under the primary tier items so
we'll just give these guys of 1/2 of a
menu item like so ok now let's go ahead
and style them so we want position to be
relative in case we want to sub items we
can position them we're going to use
flex to display them and we're going to
align a line - Wayne hit - items that's
the center so let's save that and
that did not seem to work what did I do
wrong there
you
you
let's give some padding here padding of
12 pixels 15 pixels save yeah oh it is a
pity there we go so now it gave some
updating about gave up a order - left of
three pixels solid transparent is going
to be used for like an active item or
something so we can make the little left
of it active if we want there and that's
pretty much it there for the
that guy so we need to do one more rule
here right above this for the app - menu
itself today we're to do a rule for this
nobody not and we need to say margin -
bottom zero and list-style:none and
actually we just want to set margin to
this is zero
and save that and also padding to zero
so we get rid of all those guys there we
go so there's our little tags right
there and that's looking just fine and
dandy
now we could give these guys some
background colors and you know style
these all sorts of different ways but
we'll just kind of leave it at that for
now so let's now go over to our app CSS
so this guy right here and just quickly
add in a little rule for the content so
we're gonna say app - content and we
will say the we're gonna give it a min
height like I'm just gonna do an outlet
on this so you can see it outline
outline 1 pixel solid red so we'll be
able to see this guy let's make sure we
have our app content as well let's close
this down open up this yeah so there's
our app content
so that's what we're creating here so
we're gonna give it a man - height of
calculations we're gonna calculate 100
viewport height - 50 pixels and save
that and you can see it's kinda hard to
see but there's and it's now fully fully
heighted that's a it's not work clearly
but and let's give this guy a margin -
top of 50 pixels whoops
50 pixels and save and let's also
give some padding to the sky so 30
pixels of padding and a background ash
color of
'if 5b 5b 5b five and say everyone so
there is our
content area there I don't know where my
outline went for my lingo that
margin-top is causing a problem with
that guy
okay and now we need to say we did do
that margin-top so we're gonna now give
this guy a margin - left of the same
width as our side bar which we did is
230 pixels
I think I'm really need to set that up
as a variable don't we with this
230 yeah okay so in other words it
shifts over that left and right columns
there's for our side bar so that's
looking pretty good
so you can see how those guys sort of
behave and we get below certain
breakpoints and that is pretty much it
so we again we could go forever on this
but that pretty much gets the basic
layout so now it's just a matter of
finesse to where we add the breakpoints
to when we get certain breakpoints our
our sidebar collapses and grows we add a
toggle so that we can click that button
and shrink and grow the sidebar we
rearrange this so we use flex to get
this item and shift it over here to the
right we start adding in filler content
again we can use bootstrap for all of
that stuff this theme is based on
bootstrap so we can come in to our index
and inside one of these rows we can grab
in fact I'm just going to jump over here
to the browser and let's just go to get
bootstrap just to grab some code here
and we'll go to the documentation we'll
just grab a little bit of code for a
card
so let's come down here and grab a card
without a title without an image there's
a basic card right there so we'll just
grab a card and we can throw that inside
of this column and throw it inside of
this column and save there
and refresh over here so you can you
know we can start to add cards again we
can customize all of this stuff we do
have our folder that has our bootstrap
overrides CSS file where we can go in
and just read eclair any of the
bootstrap variables that have bootstrap
names you can just react lair an
override so if you come into your node
modules and we come back into bootstrap
so let's find this here so there's the
there's the bootstrap variables file
right here so for example if I want to
change the primary color this is the
button primary they have a variable in
here called primary so if I read Eclair
this variable on my own CSS sheet so
I'll come into my bootstrap override a
CSS sheet so I'll come into my customize
bootstrap right here and I'll say
primary and I'll just say pink for now
and watch what happens when I save boom
all of everything with that class of
primary is automatically overridden so
I'm overriding bootstraps variables
because in my index.html that button
down there had the class of button -
primary and I just changed the color of
the primary color in bootstrap by
overriding their variable so you can do
that with anything you can come into any
of their variables and just peek a look
at you know what the variable name is
and just use the exact same variable
name you can override anything colors
widths heights shadows transitions
anything in bootstrap you can you know
customize okay we're back here on day
two I've obviously got a little bit
shorter hair today and we're gonna
finish things off in this tutorial by
just fixing up the header and then
making the site responsive with some
automatic sidebar closing and opening so
let's go ahead and start here with the
header elements you'll remember that our
headers sort of stacked on top over here
at the top right we're gonna fix this
guy so it lays out nice and horizontally
and then we're gonna push this little
logo to make sure it's always on top of
the sidebar when we're on our desktop
view so let's come our hair back to our
app header dot s CSS sheet and we're
gonna add a couple of rules here just to
fix that so the first rule thing we're
going to
is for the app - nav so let's go ahead
and add this rule and what we're gonna
do here is we're gonna use a command
called @include and we're gonna include
the function that's called list unstyled
now what this does in SAS is it brings
in all of the lists or rather all of the
CSS that's defined inside of this and
this is actually a bootstrap function
this is defined in the bootstrap sass
files this is what makes a regular
ordered or unordered list unstyled
meaning it doesn't have bullets and
margins and things like that so we're
gonna include that for our app nav over
here and then we're also just gonna set
a couple of properties on our own so
we're going to set display to flex
that's what's gonna make it line out
horizontally then I'm gonna set the
margin bottom to zero pixels because it
has a bit of a margin included in it and
then we're gonna set the justify content
property to flex in which is what's
going to push that guy clear over to the
right side of the screen so you can now
see you over here that lined that guy up
like so and this guy's then lined up
like so so that's what that did for us
now that's lining up much much better so
lastly let's go ahead and fix this
little guy align him a little bit better
so that he can properly sit where we
want him so to do that that is going to
be another rule here and that rule is
going to be for our you'll recall if we
come over here and look at our main oops
not our main dot CSS but rather our
index file
in the index.html the bad guy is tucked
away over here let's come up into our
head section so we can see that so that
is you can see we have this li class of
drop-down and that's got our anchor tag
for the nav and then this UL class right
here so this little ul which is called
drop-down menu right is responsible for
this guy so we're gonna do a couple of
rules here to position him correctly as
well rather than the menu right we're
actually gonna be targeting this one
right here this is the anchor tag the
anchor tag is actually the little icon
right here so this one is called app -
nav item so I'm going to copy this we'll
move back to our app header and let's
just go ahead and paste that in here and
for this guy we're gonna set it to
display block and we're gonna give it
some padding padding here is gonna be 18
pixels and you can see when I save and
refresh here that just lines it up nice
and evenly on the top and bottom we're
also going to assign some line height
here of 18 pixels and color we're just
going to assign to white for now and
then we're also gonna add a transition
on this guy because we want there to be
a slight effect so we're gonna
transition the background color point
0.3 seconds and we're gonna ease that so
let's save and refresh over here and now
you can see when I hover over this guy
oops my background
oh I haven't added a background color
yet let's go ahead and do that
so let's go ahead and add some extra
rules for our so we're gonna say and
when this has the hover and this is also
actually going to be for the focus so on
both of these two states this is a group
selector here that'll be nested inside
of this rule in our sass rules here
here's we're gonna set our background
and we're just going to do RGB a and
we're just gonna go with instead of the
default point eight we're gonna set that
to point one percent opacity and let's
save that and see if that does the trick
for us
so now you can see that little teeny bit
of a hover effect on the background in
the transition we're getting there on
that element so now I can click that and
those fly out nice and lovely for us so
that is now organized properly so that's
looking good let's go ahead and work on
just a few items to make us a little bit
more responsive so the first thing we
want to do is when we reach a certain
point we want this sidebar to disappear
right now you can see that it's really
not all that responsive these middle
options here are responsive but as I
drag this window down let's kind of pull
this over a little bit you can see that
the sidebar stays active no matter how
small I get so what we want to do is
when we get to our break point for our
tablet and mobile size we want that
sidebar to automatically hide itself so
we need to set up a couple of media
queries to make it slightly more
responsive so the first one we're going
to do is just add in our main one here
let's pull this back over to our app so
we're gonna go back to our app file here
just this main app and we're gonna add
the main media query here so we'll say
at media and this one's going to be set
to a max width of 767 pixels which is
kind of a standard for tablet size and
we're gonna set the margin left to zero
so in other words up to 768 pixels this
is where these media queries will be in
effect so let's go ahead and test that
out so we'll come back over here and
let's pull this guy down and you can see
that right and we hit oh whoops
doesn't seem like that's getting
triggered there oh this media query
needs to be nested that's the issue here
so this media query right here needs to
be nested inside of this app content
rule because the app content is the one
that we want the margin left to go to
zero on remember by default we have our
margin left set to the width of the
sidebar which is what allows us to have
our content over in the content
area so let's fix that let's go ahead
and try this again and there's I should
be triggering there so whenever it's not
working like so I'm just gonna save and
make sure that's recompiling okay you
want to inspect the element and see
what's happening here so we can
right-click anywhere here and just
inspect the element and see if our rules
are actually toggling like we expect so
let's look at our app content which is
this element you can see right now it's
got the margin left of 230 pixels which
is correct
we want to set that to zero when we go
below that breakpoint so as we come down
oh it is working so you can definitely
see it's being set to zero the problem
is now we have to set also set the
sidebar one so the content is working
fine now you can see that the content is
collapsing collapsing down properly
underneath here and now we need to
collapse down this sidebar so to do that
let's move over to our sidebar and add
that guy so here inside of our apps side
bar we're gonna be adding another media
query to this app - sidebar rule just
like we did before so right here we're
gonna say @ media and this one's going
to be set to a max width of the same
thing 767 pixels so that it's triggered
whoops at the same time there and for
this rule it's going to set the left
position to negative 230 pixels so now
let's go ahead and save that and you can
see right away that's actually working
properly here so as I scale up this guy
is margin gets set to 230 and this guy's
the left position gets set and then as I
scale down our media query overrides
both of those rules and now the sidebar
automatically disappears for there so
that's now working just as we expect so
now let's go ahead and fix in this
little Content area here we just have
one small issue with the way our header
is working this issue is in our app CSS
file it's an error we made earlier you
can see that we have our app content has
a margin top of 50 pixels that's what
makes it so that our content doesn't
slide underneath our navbar there at the
top
and our navbar you can see has will also
has this minimum height set to the 100
height units minus 40 pixels
well this 40 pixels should be the same
as this 50 pixels so we need to switch
this to 50 pixels and then when we save
notice that that is gonna fix a few
issues here over in our content area
where we're just not having this one
pixel or a few pixels slide up
underneath there like we were gonna be
having before so here in our app header
file let's come down to the app search
and we are going to switch this guy out
not switch them out rather we're gonna
add another media query here so we're
going to say at media and this is going
to be at a max width here of 480 pixels
so this would be literally be our mobile
size here and we just want to set
display to none so in other words when
we get down to the phone size we don't
want this search bar to appear at all so
you can see here on tablet size we still
have it desktop we still have it but on
mobile we get rid of that all together
so we're left with just our logo and our
drop down here like this okay so next
let's go ahead and fix this HQ admin so
that it appears over here at the left by
default and not kind of floating over
here in the middle so for this one we're
going to be in the app header logo and
we're just going to come down here and
add another media query so this one's
going to be at media and we're gonna
have this one at a minimum width of 768
pixels we are going to change the Flex
so we're going to set Flex whoops I let
me fix this whole mistake right here
first before we do that and there we go
so we're gonna change the Flex to zero
zero Auto we're gonna change the display
to block and then we're also going to
set the width equal to our sidebar width
which is 230 pixels so watch what
happens here when we save you'll notice
that then this first item gets that 230
pixels width and the other items follow
suit accordingly now
that this rule right here is what's
being applied on our mobile menu by
default and then because we're doing
sort of a mobile-first approach here on
this menu and then this media query
kicks in as we get higher and higher in
our widths so that fixes this issue you
can see now we can scale this guy down
and at this point it switches it breaks
and now this flex rule is overriding
here now these three rules are shorthand
property for three separate Flex
properties here so you can see there's
the Flex grow the Flex rink and the Flex
basis properties so that's what this
when you have it whenever you see like
this flex that's a bit of a shorthand so
now we need to fix you can see here that
on our desktop view this is lining up
properly but now our nav element over
here is all scrunched over to the left
where we want that guy clear over to the
right on a desktop view so let's go
ahead and fix that that is going to be
done down inside of our app nav so we'll
scroll down here and same thing we're
just going to be adding a media query
here so we'll say at media this one when
we hit a minimum width of 768 pixels so
at least seven sixty eight so 768 and
above this is our desktop media query
then we're just going to change the
flags
so we'll say Flex is one zero Auto and
we'll save there and that does that so
now you can see on desktop these guys
are sitting down over at the right where
as our item here is clear over to the
left so let me just pull that up a
little bit bigger now so you can see how
that works so on our desktop our menus
laying out nice how we expect it to be
we get down to our tablet we still have
the search bar in the logo and then when
we get down to our mobile the search
disappears we have our logo and then our
drop down menu so that's as far as we're
gonna take the header here as far as
adding the responsive set up for that so
let's do one more quick thing here when
our sidebar appears we want this to sort
of have a bit of animation so it doesn't
just suddenly appear let's transition
that in so it slides in so we're gonna
add that with a CSS transition we need
to open up the app a sidebar CSS file so
let's open that guy up in here
and will come up to the app sidebar rule
and we're simply going to be adding a
transition property here so it really
doesn't matter where we add this I'll
just kind of stick it above this media
query here so we're gonna say transition
and we're going to transition the left
property in 0.3 I always have the habit
of just doing point 3 like that but it's
actually correct syntax to do 0.3
seconds and then we're gonna ease that
and then we're gonna do one more here
this one's going to be for the width
will also transition the width same
thing 0.3 seconds and so we have two
different transitions set on that the
actual width and the left position so
now when we come over here and our
sidebar you can kind of see how that
animates in and out so it kind of slides
out when we get down to mobile and it
sort of slides back in when we get to
our desktop one extra thing we could do
here you'll notice it's pretty quick but
as soon as I move this this is going to
animate out but we still have our margin
left that's sort of left over so watch
here really closely kind of pay
attention to this area right here so as
we come down in watch what happens going
to come up you can see the margin left
appears first and then the animation
slides over so we really want to change
that margin left so that these things
get pushed over in a nice smooth
animation as well so let's add that next
that is going to be and over in our app
CSS file and on our app content rule you
can see here we have a margin left
property and that's the one we want to
add a transition to so same thing here
let's just go ahead and add a transition
this one's going to be set to the margin
- left property 0.3 seconds with an ease
and then let's go ahead and save that
and let's test this out one more time so
when we come down it hides and we would
come up now you can see that we're
getting this area animated as well
meaning the content watch when it slides
over it's also pushed in an animation so
you can kind of see how that works there
so that's nice and smooth so perfect
next let's go ahead and remove the red
border here from our little sort of that
we added earlier so let's just get rid
of this border rule altogether we don't
need that anymore
as that was just when we were doing a
bit of wire framing and now that's
behaving really nicely so most of the
work here is done the last little thing
we're gonna do in this tutorial is then
when we're down on our mobile phone so
we're at our mobile menu everything's
hidden we need a way to toggle out that
sidebar with a hamburger menu or a menu
toggle up here in the in the header to
where we can click that and slide that
guy in and slide it out as we may need
to access of course those menu links
because right now the only way we can
get that back is if we were to suddenly
go above that break point and then our
sidebar appears so let's go ahead and
add that mobile navigation toggle next
so we are in our index dot HTML file
here for this as we need to add the
anchor tag that's going to serve as the
little toggle for this so we're gonna
add this right after our HQ admin logo
or rather title site title so this is
just gonna be an anchor tag we're gonna
give it a class of app let me fix that
really quick app - sidebar underscore
underscore toggle and the href here is
just going to be blank this isn't a true
anchor tag for a link I'm gonna say data
- Data - toggle equals sidebar if we
wanted to be setting up some JavaScript
hooks for this we use this and then
we'll also just give it an aria-label
which is going to be for our
accessibility and we're just going to
call this the hide sidebar so that
screen readers and whatnot would be able
to show that properly and then that's
all we're gonna do there and then we'll
just close off the anchor tag like so
alright let's go ahead and save that I'm
gonna turn on my wrapping here once more
whoops so that wraps down so you can see
that full entire rule there so there is
the selector for our sidebar toggle now
we're going to jump back into our CSS
and we are going to add in some rules
here to make our toggle appear so we're
gonna be using font awesome because
we're already using that for a few
things to add
in the bars so we're gonna have that
little sort of hamburger menu so we can
actually do it right inside of the
anchor tag we can do that with a span
tag or something like this we could open
a span tag and say class equals fa fa -
bars and then that would make those bars
appear like so so you can see this is
gonna be our little guy that we click
and toggle that guy down with so let's
jump over and add some of the CSS to our
app header so inside of our app header a
CSS file let's go ahead and add this
rule so it's gonna be dot app - side bar
underscore underscore toggle because
what we named that and I'm just gonna
hit return a few times just to kind of
move this up to the center of the screen
there so it's easier to read so we're
gonna give this guy some padding we'll
say zero 15 pixels and then let's what's
there we go let's go ahead and give it
some color we'll just set it to white
and we're gonna give some line height
and we are also going to transition so
we want this guy to transition our
background color just like we did on our
item over there on the other side the
little toggle for the drop down menu the
background color 0.3 seconds and ease
and that's looking good there then we're
going to go ahead and add the hover and
the focus rules so I say whoops
ampersand so on focus and ampersand
hover this is our grouped CSS selector
here we're gonna set color to just white
again no change there but here's where
we can set the background color to
something else and rgba we can just do
like we did before and just set it to
0.1 or something like that we're gonna
set the text decoration to none so
there's no weird
underlines or anything like that when we
hover
and you can see now how that's working
there so come over here so you can see
that when I hover over there I'm getting
that nice little background effect there
so now we need to position this little
span tag a little bit better so we're
gonna write a little rule below this guy
that's called - app sidebar toggle a
child of span which is where actually FA
bars reside and we'll just set that to
display:inline-block and save and then
we can add some padding to this - so
we'll just say zero I don't know 15
pixels or something so we're just trying
to move this guy what's gonna 115 there
I'll just do 15 altogether so we're just
adding a little bit of padding to get
this guy at the sort of center itself in
the bar there and that looks fine enough
for me so there's our little toggle for
the menu to be toggled in and out and
that's looking pretty good
so one issue you'll note is that when we
come down to our mobile menu it'd be
better if this little guy was on the
opposite side of our logo we don't want
them in the middle we sort of want them
on the left edge so we can do that with
flexbox by just switching the display
order so let's go ahead and add a media
query up in this sidebar toggle we'll
just do this one before I guess we'll
just do it right here where my cursor is
so we'll say at media and this is going
to be at a maximum width of 767 pixels
so in other words this is tablet and
below we're going to change the order
here so we want to say order negative 1
that's an easy way to just force it all
the way to the left so let's test that
out so we're on desktop you can see it's
still order number 2 but when we get
down to tablet it swaps over and it's
now at order number zero essentially or
negative 1 that's it's over there for
our tablet and mole so the last thing we
would do here is we need to set up a
little bit of JavaScript so that when we
click this guy we're
are going to add or remove a class from
our HTML going to move into JavaScript
here you'll remember earlier that we set
up inside of our JavaScript folder here
in the demo rather in our source we have
our sass then we have our JavaScript and
we have this one called custom and this
custom javascript file is the one we're
going to be using to write a little bit
of jQuery you could do this with vanilla
JavaScript as well but since bootstrap 4
requires jQuery we already have it we're
just going to use it here so what we're
gonna do is we're just going to set a
little bit of toggle javascript so that
when we click our toggle menu we add or
remove a CSS class to our app and then
we're gonna write a little bit of CSS
that either hides and shows the menu
based on that hook if you will so let's
go ahead and write this little
JavaScript first so this is just going
to be here an anonymous the jQuery
function here which looks like this and
we are going to say use strict then
we're just going to set up a little bit
of jQuery test here so we're gonna go
with we're gonna be targeting that data
toggle attribute we added so we're gonna
say data dash toggle equals sidebar
remember this is right here we called
this data - toggle equal to sidebar so
this is jQuery targeting this specific
anchor tag only that's what this little
guy right here is doing and then we're
going to say dot click and then we're
gonna write here in a function we'll add
our event whoops I can type that out
quickly keep typing that incorrectly
just event there and then we'll write
this function here I know this is kind
of it let's push this over so we can see
this a bit better there we go
okay and we're just gonna do a little
test here we're just gonna say it's a
console dot log sidebar toggle was
clicked just to make sure this event is
actually firing before we go pull our
hair out trying to troubleshoot why it's
not working so let's come over here and
that should refresh automatically so
when we click this I'm not getting
anything in my console so something is
working oh we have an error oh yeah here
we go this is supposed to be a dollar
sign there's a problem that's the
shorthand for jQuery so let's try that
again and click that's still not working
there oh I think we need this here there
we go so this is the little piece I was
missing there for the jQuery shorthand
syntax or whatever for there on ready
event okay so you can see it's working
now every time I click this little
button watch down here you can see that
the sidebar toggle was clicked and this
will increment over here two six seven
eight every single time I click this so
there it goes it's working so I know now
that my hook is working so now what I
can do here is let's delete this console
log and we're just gonna say event dot
prevent defaults so that just prevents
whatever the anchor tag wants to do by
default for this specific event and then
we'll write another rule here so we're
gonna toggle the dot app and we're gonna
say toggle class now this is a jQuery
function that just adds or removes this
class based on whether it's currently
present we're not currently prot present
so we're gonna call this our sidebar
- toggled something like that okay so
now if we come over here and look one
more time so we should see on our
inspector if we look up here at our app
remember this is the this is where we're
adding this for to write to our body
class of app it should add another class
here called sidebar toggled if it
doesn't exist
so let's test it out you can see sure
enough it appeared right there sidebar
toggled and if I click it again it
should disappear and that's how that
little jQuery thing does so we're just
adding or removing a simple CSS class
here and you can kind of see where we're
going with this we're gonna add a little
bit of CSS to this specific class name
that sets the margin left and the left
position of our elements to either be
you know hidden or display just like we
did manually with our media queries so
let's do that so we will jump back and
add that we're gonna add that one on our
since this is sort of sidebar related
type of stuff we're gonna add that in
the sidebar dot CSS file and we'll add a
little rule here called I would call
that sidebar
now got a big hard to can't remember
what we just called that thing we called
it sidebar - toggled so we'll just paste
that in there sidebar toggled so this
one we're gonna write as a descendant
selector so anytime we have the class of
app and then somewhere along the line a
child of sidebar toggled we want to
override a few things so we're gonna
write we're just going to write this one
in manual CSS so we need to change our
sidebar it's self so you'll see that
that one's up here in this sidebar it
has the media query right here for left
of negative to 30 so we're gonna change
that so app - sidebar we're gonna set
the left position to negative 230 pixels
except this is going to be left 0 pixels
okay let's test this out so we'll come
down to our mobile that disappears when
we click this we are getting um let's
see this one should have overridden that
app side bar toggled oh whoops this side
bar toggle is a class on the app so it
should be app dot side bar toggled
because both of these are together right
and then any child of app side bar so
that should be the way that works there
we go
so you can see that I can click that I
either add the class it slides out the
left menu I click it it removes the
class which means the default left of
negative 230 is taking over and that's
how easy you can add a little toggle
here so this is pretty much now complete
we have we could do a little bit of
extra I mean we could of course do tons
and tons of CSS we could maybe hide this
little toggle on desktop view maybe we
only want it to appear on mobile or
maybe we want to have the ability to
slide in and out that sidebar on desktop
it's kind of up to you but batten is now
fully functional to where we have our
sidebar toggle we have all the mobile
and responsiveness set up and we have
essentially built the framework for a
fully responsive admin style theme based
on bootstrap for I hope you've enjoyed
this tutorial and learned a few tips and
tricks along the way I'd love for you to
come over and join me on my channel and
see a few other CSS HTML design
Photoshop related tutorials that I'm
putting out over there so we will see
you in the next one